The second category of issues is coordination.
Remember that we have heterogeneous distributed application,
multiple things going on at the same time.
And these multiple things have to synchronize across certain actions.
Okay, and how is that going to be provided?
The two main categories of a synchronization are synchronous applications,
synch, synchronous communications and asynchronous communications.
Synchronous means that when one piece of the application initiates that
particular message or interaction that it
waits until it gets a reply back, a response back, before continuing.
Often synchronous types of interactions are clocked.
That means that there's some heartbeat or
some other measure of when it can do certain things.
On the other hand asynchronous communication means the client can continue to
execute after it sent the message and it's notified
when the response comes back and it can take appropriate steps at that point.
Obviously asynchronous is more general, but writing code for
dealing with a, asynchronous coordination is a little trickier,
it makes it a little harder to understand.
So once again there's a trade off.
Another question with respect to coordination is, who's in charge here?
Okay, is it the client or the server?
You've no doubt seen situations where the server is capable of pushing things
out to the client such as web pages which you want to update with current events
or it could be that the client requests information as it pulls from the server.
Deciding how you're going to deal with that is a key design question in any
distributed application.
It's always the case with such applications that robustness is important.
What this means is that the system can deal with situations where one or
more of its components goes down.
Think that you send out a message and you don't get any response back.
And the reason that you don't get any response back is that the the piece of
the application you were dealing with goes down.
How does your part of the application deal with that?
Think for example, if you were user facing you don't want to just wait there and
leave the user in limbo.
You want to provide perhaps some time map on
a message acknowledgment and be able to let the user know what went on.
Similar to robustness is availability.
How does the system appear to the user as far as being available?
Is it 24/7, type application?
Does it have set maintenance times?
How does it deal with load situations?
That is, does it get so slow that the user gets frustrated?
All those kinds of questions.
Persistence we've already mentioned.
In general this means how a server stayed maintained.
One obvious approach is with a data base.
It might be a file system, but nevertheless the choice has to be made.
And if you've got multiple clients talking to the system,
how is that concurrency handled?
Okay, how does the server part of the application deal with all
these multiple users?
Related to that is the transaction and
integrity constraints which we've talked about on the previous issue.